>> Carley: PRESIDENT BIDEN
IGNORING QUESTIONS FROM
REPORTERS ONCE AGAIN AND DISSING
THEM OUT LOUD AS THEY WERE --
SHUFFLED OUT OF THE ROOM BY HIS
PEOPLE.
>> AM I THE ONLY PERSON IN THE
WORLD THAT DOES THIS?
SERIOUSLY, SERIOUSLY.
>> Todd: JOE CONCHA, AUTHOR OF
"COME ON, MAN," JOINING US NOW.
DOES THAT JOE NOT GET THAT THERE
HAS NEVER BEEN A PRESIDENT MORE
CODDELED BY THE PRESS AND HE IS
HIDING BIDEN?
>> Joe: IF BIDEN'S PREDECESSOR
WOULD HAVE WHINED LIKE THAT, MY
GOSH, THAT IS AN ATTACK ON US?
WE NEED ACCESS TO THE QUESTION.
I KNOW, JIM ACOSTA WOULD BE IN
THERAPY FOR A WEEK.
HE'S DONE ZERO LIVE TELEVISION
INTERVIEWS THIS YEAR, HE DID
TWO, ONE WITH NBC AND CBS,
PRETAPES, WHY IS THAT?
TO PRESENT AS A PACKAGE AFTER.
MAYBE EMBARRASSING MOMENTS WERE
LEFT ON EDITY ROOM FLOOR.
BIDEN HAS DONE THREE SOLO PRESS
CONFERENCES THIS YEAR.
OBAMA DID 25.
WHY IS BIDEN HIDING?
CAN'T ANSWER WHY ARE GAS PRICES
GOING UP?
WHOSE FAULT IS IT?
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT IN A
SECOND.
THAT LIVE REPORT, GUN IN THE
BACK OF THE CAR AND FENTANYL
COMING IN, KILLING 300 AMERICANS
PER DAY ON AVERAGE, THEY HAVE NO
GOOD ANSWERS AND THE PRESIDENT
IS BEING HIDDEN.
>> Carley: MENTION GAS PRICES
AND INFLATION, THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY'S DISCUSSION
WITH REPORTERS YESTERDAY, KARINE
JEAN-PIERRE TRIED TO LECTURE
PETER DOOCY AFTER HE ASKED ABOUT
GAS PRICES GOING UP AGAIN,
WATCH.
>> YOU SAID THE PRESIDENT WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR GAS PRICES
COMING DOWN, IS THE PRESIDENT
RESPONSIBLE FOR GAS PRICES GOING
UP?
>> SO IT IS A LOT MORE NUANCE
THAN THAT, RIGHT, PETER, YOU
KNOW THIS.
THERE HAS BEEN GLOBAL
CHALLENGES, PANDEMIC AND PUTIN'S
WAR.
>> Carley: JOE, IT IS NOT MORE
NUANCE, YOU INCREASE OUTPUT AND
PRICES GO DOWN AND LISTEN TO THE
PRESIDENT AND EVERY WORD IS
ANTI-OIL AND GAS.
>> Joe: ONE HEADLINE FROM THE
"WASHINGTON POST," GAS PRICES
HIGH ISSUE BIDEN PUTS OIL
COMPANIES ON NOTICE.
>> Carley: I SAW THAT THIS
MORNING.
>> Joe: THAT IS PLAY DEFENSE.
WE'VE LOWERED GAS PRICES FASTER
THAN ANY IN A DECADE.
THIS IS LIKE ME GAINING 50
POUNDS AND I LOSE SIX AND I SAY
I HAVE NEVER LOST MORE WEIGHT
THAT QUICKLY AND NOW GAINING AND
TRYING TO BLAME SOMEBODY OR
SOMETHING ELSE, IF IT IS NOT
PUTIN, IT IS OIL COMPANIES, THIS
IS UPON HAING FIVE WEEKS BEFORE
MIDTERM AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AREN'T GOING TO CARE WHY GAS
PRICES ARE ABOVE $6 IN
CALIFORNIA, THEY WILL SAY THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS NO CLUE HOW
TO FIX THIS PROBLEM.
>> Carley: DRIVING TO THE
POLL --
>> Todd: CONCHA STOLE MY WET
LOSS IS -- WE HAVE BEEN
PREDICTING AND THE OPEC MEETING
PREDICTING IN THE MONTH LEADING
UP TO THE ELECTION AND WE ARE
FIVE WEEKS OUT, HOW FREAKED OUT
ARE THEY?
>> Joe: I GUESS THE FIST PUMP
WITH THE SAUDI PRINCE DID NOT
WORK, THEY HAVE NO BUMPER
STICKER, THEY CAN'T RUN ON
ANYTHING POSITIVE, THEY BLAME
OIL COMPANIES OR MAKE THIS
MIDTERM A REFERENDUM ON DONALD
TRUMP WHO HASN'T BEEN IN OFFICE
FOR 22 MONTHS, GO FIGURE.
>> Todd: PICK UP A COPY OF JOE
CONCHA'S NEW BOOK, "COME ON,
N
MAN -- YOU FORGOT ONE THING IN
THE FIRST ANSWER, WHEN HE TALKS
LIVE, HE CONJURES THE DEAD, YOU
LEFT THAT OUT OF WHY DOESN'T HE
TALK LIVE?
>> Joe: